since we're talking about oil for a
second why isn't the news talking about
the fact that joe biden's stopping the
keystone pipeline
that's just putting more money in
putin's pockets
by making us less energy independent
and nobody's talking about under
president trump we went to number one
i think we were number one saudi arabia
was number two and russia was number
three
right by not having the keystone
pipeline we're making ourselves
vulnerable
again uh to russia uh
having a bigger sphere in geopolitics
and not only that but
let's talk about for a second the the
democrats always like to say that they
are green and they care about the
environment and they are these stewards
listen
the oil is coming into our country one
way or another
it's either coming by rail it's coming
by ship it's coming by
automobile right which causes more of a
carbon
footprint pipeline or any of the other
three
uh things i just mentioned and so that
shows me
they don't actually care and joe biden's
policy
uh doesn't have anything to do with the
green effect whatsoever
there's a lot to break down uh so it i
believe it is it is
simply true the keystone pipeline a
pipeline transferring oil
consumes less carbon than freight
delivery correct
then there's a question about which
leaks more and i i believe and i could
be wrong so fact check me that it still
leans heavily against freight delivery
that freight is more likely to spill or
leak than the pipeline does but the
pipeline did have many leaks
so i i gotta say you know what let me
give this one to
to the left well just for the sake of
argument i'll say okay fine the keystone
pipeline you didn't like and you shut it
down because you believe in the
environment
i'm so glad that you're concerned about
renewable energies and reducing our
carbon emissions
so when do we open our new power plant
our new nuclear power plants when do we
get these thorium salt reactors online
which are zero carbon emission carbon
neutral
renewable and safe and they oppose it
even tulsi gabbard was opposed to this
and i like tulsi gabbard we have a
fusion uh
research facility at jpl the jet
propulsion laboratory in california that
looks like it's like on the horizon
where's that at
who's stopping that who who's why isn't
that in the headlines of every paper
saying every day if we want to talk
about green energy
and and i agree like i think if we want
to be number one energy exporters energy
production
fusion energy is going to change the
world so if we if we accomplish that
then oil is a thing of the past for now
the best energy
i believe the best energy return on
energy invested is nuclear energy
for some reason they don't want you know
what i think it is
i don't think it's about energy i think
it's about
holding this this military uh um
yeah the petrodollar yeah yeah it's it's
about having control strategically
around the planet and justifying it
so long as everyone's using oil and and
and they have to use the dollar to
exchange
it and we have the weapons and we're
positioned then
that's it it's control for the
establishment uh
uh two things i agree with you if we
went off the petro dollar it could be
the american dollar could be completely
useless it would be wiped out yeah
it'd be totally wiped out and i'll be
broke overnight as for the pipeline i
agree it's messy it spills there's lots
i don't know 20 30 how many spills last
year there's like 26 yeah quite a bit of
spills
but it's like they're saying look we
have the cutter turkey pipeline
so it doesn't the oil is going to spill
regardless of if it's coming out of
russia or if it's coming out of canada
but it's like they don't want to spill
it on the floor of the ivory tower they
don't want to mess up
our luscious land but they just want to
mess up their luscious land and they
still want to transport the
get the same dirty crap so i think it's
insane i think
i don't know i mean i'm not i don't live
on the land i know that people that live
on the land that are having a pipeline
drought drove through their yards and
getting oil spilled into their crops and
stuff
are devastated but it's if we're gonna
drill it out of the ground anyway
when i when i talk to people about
keystone they immediately say it's it's
not about oil spills
it's about the native americans right to
the land and then i'm like
okay well if there's legitimate land
ownership issues and i absolutely
respect like you know we go back in time
and there are a lot of violations of
trees and things like that but
that doesn't mean shut the pipeline down
it's already built i mean you've got
people who have spent all these
resources on it
i suppose maybe it means move it or i
don't know what your the argument really
becomes because
joe biden's reason for shutting it down
it was it was what climate change
you know so it feels like they're moving
the goalposts in that regard that when
it becomes an issue of native american
sacred land it's kind of like
all right i guess but weren't we just
talking about climate change because i'm
definitely willing to have that
conversation i don't i don't want to
steal anybody's land you know what i
mean like i believe in private property
rights so if there's legit claims like
oh you got a problem keystone if you're
building on someone else's property
why aren't we having that argument then
why is it all about climate change and
you're ignoring it if you cared about
the native americans maybe that would be
the forefront of this conversation
and the no dapl protests were focused on
that
but they were sending in cops to go shut
it down and where are they where are the
democrats
it's all just climate change is the core
issue meanwhile
the more we slow ourselves down in our
energy production it's just benefiting
china
who is building more coal power plants
i'll tell you man
if they listen my problem with the
climate change crowd
is that they want me to sacrifice they
want me to do all these things i'm
absolutely willing to do
i love trees i love nature i love being
out in the wilderness and all that stuff
we're building a little chicken city
it's great i want solar panels and
batteries absolutely yep solar power we
try it we try and do our best
biodegradable uh kerrig cups because we
want to make sure
for sure we're recycling it's it's the
it's what's it called pla it's the it's
the cornstarch version stuff
we're very very eco-friendly here not
pla that's a type of plastic
all right all right what is it then
what's the cellulose maybe i'm not sure
i thought it was i thought yeah i
thought pla was this
was i could be wrong i need a plastics
expert it's
it's it's made of it's made of
cornstarch it's like a plastic
so it breaks down and so we do these
things and then i look to
these celebrities and they're flying in
private jets they're buying beachfront
property and i'm like
so are you really concerned about this
because you'd be building nuclear power
plants if you really cared about i'm not
really concerned about the
the carbon emissions because we can
recapture it and turn it into graphene
by depositing carbon dioxide onto
palladium i mean there's tests and
studies like why isn't that also on the
like
i think you gotta think a little bit a
little bit forward politics yeah they've
got a boogeyman
they got the money they need to sell the
oil and they're acting like climate
change is important but they got to sell
the oil
i think machine turning i think climate
change is a big problem and i think
these elites
their mentality is if everyone else
sacrifices i won't have to
i'm like sorry like who are you to fly
in a private jet and by beachfront
property because you think
everyone else is going to do the heavy
lifting and you don't have to that's
like imagine a roommate
and he's just like sitting back like you
guys clean the house i'm just going to
sit here and eat pizza all night and do
whatever i want it's like nah we all
gotta pitch in bro
you can't be the one complaining about
how the house is all messy and then be
the one who's sitting in your room
playing video games all night drinking
mountain dew and eating pizza
like everybody's gotta pitch in to clean
this place up so when i hear this
from them i don't i don't trust them i
don't believe them i don't i'm sorry
i do think climate change is a problem i
just don't believe them when they say
they care
so when keystone gets shut down there
are so many questions around it
is it more dangerous are there more
spills there's arguments that's not true
is it more energy efficient is there
less carbon emissions from it
so maybe it was a net positive well i
don't believe the liars who are
telling me all these things then and
then bsing me and who also reject
nuclear power
sorry i've not heard a good argument
against nuclear power the only argument
i ever hear is fukushima three mile
island in chernobyl
and i'm like look chernobyl early
technology
soviet union shoddy authoritarianism
like shoddy workmanship authoritarianism
essentially slave labor the whole thing
was was a failure and it collapsed and
it was really really bad chernobyl was
bad
fukushima massive earthquake massive
earthquake
flood giant flood so i understand that's
the best argument against nuclear power
it was the tsunami and then the it was
the earthquake and then the tsunami that
came in
and that the reason it's a good example
is because they built fukushima
correctly
and a natural disaster occurred causing
this damage i'll have that argument
absolutely
but we also have thorium salt reactors
and we can build them inland and away
from fault lines and other places like
this doesn't produce corium it wouldn't
have the
impact on the earth and they're both
types of nuclear power but they're
completely different chemical reactions
so
so where is it where is you know we we
have this stuff on the horizon we hear
about fourth generational nuclear power
in europe it's buried under the fear of
ignorance people don't understand the
difference
or often of thorium and or is it a
boogeyman freaking weaponize
nuclear sounds scary right so they can
tell other voters no no don't let them
do it vote for us and we'll save you
and then in the meantime they actually
just it's a detriment to everybody else
when they restrict this technology
granted i think everybody's in favor of
fusion so if we get the jpl's fusion
ignition
you know to happen then it's going to be
you know then the us dollar would
collapse probably and the entire world
would have
unlimited energy and well fusion's not
unlimited
it's not it's it's just it's like it's
great tens of thousands of years worth
in in like a piece like it does it's not
unlimited it just goes
for a long long time energy return on
energy invested is that high
it's high like we can produce a lot of
energy with less input into it
but i don't think it's like you know
cold fusion is like the theoretical
great like we're talking about like
regular fusion they're trying to get
ignition where
you know they can make the process yeah
when the when the deuterium collides and
becomes
uh helium it releases uh like a leftover
form of matter that's extracted as heat
which then can be converted into
like a steam which could create a laser
to continue the reaction and then
you're creating more heat than is needed
to produce the laser
long scientific story sure just keep
pumping deuterium in which is in
all over the ocean you know we have a
lot of it it's politics let's just slap
a name on it
green fusion yes it's perfect
all we need is a good pr stunt that's
right green fusion
yeah don't call it nuclear yeah we
should we should uh
how about we don't call it nuclear and
we call it you know green decay
no decay is too negative right what's a
word we can use instead of nuclear
energy
you know no no no no so it's like green
green fusion's nice
green radiant band or something green
fusion well but if we're talking about
nuclear power plants which is different
from the fusion what can we say
it's also a type of nuclear power that's
the crazy thing they're all that all
this has happened in the nucleus of
atoms so
it just depends on the type of fusion
the green fusion deal
yeah who can oppose the green fusion i
don't think anyone yeah we'll call it
the green energy
atomic energy yes the green energy deal
there we go all right do you support the
green energy deal definitely oh there we
go congratulations sounds enticing tell
me about it
does that have anything to do with race
relationships like you know they're
really good the democrats which is
something i think we could learn from
them
they're great at naming these bills you
know they'll call it the
equality act which we all know is yep
and equal and has nothing to do with
equity
and so we need to do a better job like
why would you vote
against the save the puppies and kittens
act
why would you do that don't you love the
dolphins too
save the puppies act what does that do
it provides 17 billion dollars
to bomb things well you see why are you
calling the save the pipes
well we saw a video of a dog in syria
yeah and we were concerned that the
militants there might harm it so we're
going to save the puppies
by bombing syria and taking their oil
because the dogs could get sick from the
oil
yes and the average american doesn't
understand all of the pork that goes
into it and they don't understand
the new covid bill doesn't actually a
hundred percent
go to our paychecks and two american
citizens
and then they use that as propaganda
to say oh see the republicans won't vote
for this bill
meanwhile the republicans understand the
poison
pill that went into the bill have you
read 1984
i have not it's great it's by george
orwell about dystopian reality
in the year 1984 um and he wrote it
before the year so it's like a
futuristic
world war where there's these two giant
war powers basically and they're just
pure propaganda
and you're always at war or you're at
peace or you're a war or you're a war
with someone else
and all you're getting is news media
they have this thing called double speak
and this is basically double speak
they'll call it the ministry of
peace and that's where they declare war
that's their war department
and that's what they're doing with these
bills it's it's
you know i don't know what is the
patriot act well patriot act well look
at them
seeking justice but doing it in an
unjust way burning down cities yes
remember that in the name of peace you
remember the cnn article that said meet
the antivir group who seeks peace
through violence yes
no joke that was like cnn wrote that oh
my god
he's through violence yeah that's just
like
you know i can't say i i i
i will never i will never run for office
but i swear if i was in congress if i
was in the senate or whatever
i'd draft a bill called the like the
donald trump is the worst president act
and it would it would just do all these
awesome things it would be like
you know the people get the people the
checks they want this is so
implicit in our system in our video
games and our movies like
the heat there's a bad guy causing cast
the the hero kills him and then
everyone's
happy again and like so it's in our
brains like oh if you destroy the enemy
there will be peace that's that's why
wonder woman was a great movie do you
see wonder woman the first one
uh i'm gonna spoil it for everybody it's
fairly old at this point
but basically wonder woman believes if
she defeats the god of war
everyone will be live happily ever after
and war will end
and then you know chris pine's character
is like it doesn't work that way people
just fight sometimes
and then when she defeats ares the god
of war nothing changes
because all he was doing was whispering
in people's ears the people were
carrying on
they were fighting and so it's a cool
movie because it's ideas
you think defeating this one bad guy
solves all your problems
the left the left believes in this
they're like trump is the problem trump
is the problem we have to vote for by
now biden's doing the same things
it's worse actually trump gave more
people stimulus checks
than then biden is and people are
surprised and now biden is means testing
it
so less people are getting uh people are
getting less money
and they're surprised to find that out
but you know to be fair the left still
hates trump more than this
but they genuinely believe a lot of
people thought vote out trump and then
it'll be utopia
there's this funny meme where it was
like y'all are so dumb if you think
biden's going to bomb syria you're
making this up
and it's just like now it gets shared
over and over and over again yeah
because it's like all the gloating trump
supporters like high-fiving each other
and laughing like told you so
and don't forget the anti-war
progressives who are laughing too saying
told you so as well
and then you have you know for what it's
for for whatever reason
the establishment shill types or
tribalists just don't care they're like
whatever
you know well i think the work that
we're doing going into 2022 is so
critically important and here's why
you know here we're talking about the
media that gets to write
whatever it wants and there's no
accountability
none we can't hold the media's feet to
their fire
right and we can't hold them accountable
and then we have these politicians like
cuomo
and where is the justice for his actions
and so
i think the average feeling of the
american person
is they feel so discouraged because they
feel like they have no power
they can't hold anybody accountable the
people that lead them
the people that represent them and
ultimately the people that they see on
tv who
lied to them and that's why 2022 is
important because we finally had the
opportunity to do a couple things
if you're a conservative or if you want
to
take over peacefully democratically the
republican party
2022 is your opportunity to use the
primary
democratic process to replace these
america last politicians with america
first
ones and i'm just encouraging everybody
to get involved that this is your final
moment that if you want to have
accountability in the process
then join the voting process
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you